look at the newsstand you know I mean
it's a cacophony of famous people of
people want to be famous with blurbs all
around anise and it's supposed to be and
you know this part that's supposed to be
creativity in in journalism my god it's
unbelievable it's shocking I mean how
can happen two hundred magazines you
know do the same cover you know that's
that's always there an avatar to go home
and watch our tight I you watch our two
commercials on TV and I don't like
really I'm not kidding I don't we I
don't really understand what what the
hell made half of them I don't
understand what they're talking about
yeah and and most people don't
understand even if they see something
that they kind of enjoy they don't
remember the name of the product you
know so I mean I think I don't I don't
see anything I mean these people to keep
talking about they do it we're on the
advent of coming up with the creative
evolution I don't see it you know I
don't at the same time I know there's
got to be talent out there i don't i'm
not sure who's telling them what to do
yep yep you have to have an
understanding you have to understand
understand that everything that i go
back to what I said before everything
you do you have to have a solar farm if
you come up with idea a big idea it if
you if you show it this to somebody your
wife your friend or a client they should
go holy they should your head coach
should go back a foot you know it should
be sent to be such an is such a
surprising idea the only chance you have
to do anything this memorable has to be
a shock when you first see it you know
and what people do is they think they
just show that so the work is so
unambitious you know television
commercials are little films you know
something's going on and you don't quite
know what's going on and you say well
what is it about that you're looking for
who the client is then when you see it
you say oh I don't get it yeah sorry I
tried it until until it's
wasteland of creativity unfortunately
and I can't believe there isn't talent
that there because i think you know i
pay people i have fans who profess yo a
love of my work etc said i said it gotta
be something to gotta learn from it what
they got to be learning from it is that
when you do something it should be it
should be a knockout idea you know and
and in most cases certainly in certainly
in editorial and in in which i only did
for 10 years for Esquire and I and you
know and then then now in the same or
not but but but you have to yell when
your every cover is when it hit when it
was on Lou stand people some people what
I mean the culture what apeshit on
sarn't summer they look at anyone will
you know go to a newsstand today isn't
did not memorable forget about something
being culturally being a culture buster
there's nothing there that you could
possibly remember there's an air today a
hearse there today but with three
magazines they talk about they get an
award that cellar etc and you look at
the cubbies and I don't know they're
nothing you know they have all the same
cover you know
that's the that's the big problem you
know I mean I'm talking about people
about your young design is not not being
ambitious enough etcetera etcetera one
of the problems is is that you know
certainly in magazine design there's a
lot of terrific talent doing editor I
mean when you get this society
publication designer sense for you there
were Awards every yo a book and on your
end and you look through it at is life
terrific spreads in it a lot of exciting
stuff going on you know this talent
there and then they show the best
coverage of the year and in it and there
nothing you know